entre les mains de ces prisonniers un
cercueil en bois qu'ils viennent
d'assemblée pièce par pièce pour les
morts dus coronavirus un geste de
solidarité de la part de ces détenus
comme eux une centaine d'autres
prisonniers équatoriens ont été mis à
contribution pour fabriquer quelques 350
cercueil le gouvernement équatorien
dépassé par le nombre de morts a assuré
que ces cercueils serait remis en
priorité aux familles les plus démunies
ayant perdu un proche en raison de la
pandémie et il y a urgence à guayaquil
capitale économique du pays devenu ville
martyre près de 800 cadavres ont été
laissés dans les habitations bien dans
la rue faute de place à la morgue et en
raison de services funéraires débordé
dans cet hôpital qui accueille les
patients atteints du coc vite 19
les médecins pare au plus pressé dans la
tente de près triage qui relie à celle
ci on reçoit directement les patients
les auxiliaires médicaux et le médecin
contre les signes vitaux et détermine la
sévérité du cac si le patient a des
symptômes bénins aux modérés il est
conduit à l'hôpital de campagne où il
reçoit les soins nécessaires
toutefois si le patient est dans une
condition critique
il est directement transporté dans la
salle de trauma de l'hôpital
plupart mais pour les familles
l'angoissé est à son paroxysme c'est
angoissant parce qu'ils ne nous disent
rien rien on sait que le pronostic
changent rarement mais ils peuvent au
moins nous le dire non parce que nos
proches sont là qu'est ce qui leur
arrive
selon les chiffres officiels plus de 300
personnes sont déjà décédées des suites
du coronavirus dans la deuxième
agglomération du pays
quant aux experts et préviennent rien qu
à guayaquil et dans le reste de la
province d'ucayali le nombre de décès
pourrait être compris entre 2500 et 3500
ces prochains mois un véritable
cauchemar pour cette cité portuaire
encore surnommé la perle du pacifique il
y à peu